which helps explain why officials in
moscow are so agitated by the impact of
sanctions
and have warned the people of lithuania
to expect retaliation for their
government's actions
this example shows that you cannot trust
either verbal statements by the west or
written ones russia will certainly
respond to such hostile actions
appropriate measures are being worked
out between departments and will be
taken in the near future their
consequences will have a serious
negative impact on the population of
lithuania
it's a threat some lithuanians have long
anticipated baltic countries differently
from
many other countries of european union
didn't have any illusions about the true
attempts and ideas of russia a threat to
one or all of the baltic states would
constitute a threat to nato
many in the atlantic alliance maintain
an armed presence there this was the
german chancellor visiting his country's
soldiers in lithuania just two weeks ago
like many other european leaders olaf
schadz says his country will defend
every centimeter of nato territory donna
kane al jazeera
berlin
joining us now from brussels is rasa
yuknan who's a member of the european
parliament and was lithuania's defense
minister uh it's good to have you with
us um what do you make of russia's
statements that any measures
russia takes would harm the population
of lithuania is that a threat
first of all lithuania
is not applying any
national unilateral
restrictions and
its
transit is going and not
yet been not stopped or banned not at
all
passengers are going as they were going
and goods
only er sanctions were implemented
fourth package of sanctions in march and
now it's time game time for
implementation
russia knew everything in advance
and only steel and iron is
not allowed to go through
i see the situation as
more as
kremlin information information attack
what they are doing used to do all the
time and now they are doing
maybe because
important eu and nato summits are coming
they are trying to threaten all of us
not only lithuania but
these two
important
alliances
because they think that
uh somebody will be afraid
scared
they think that maybe because of that
somebody will
think that
is they will stop
support for ukraine
or maybe they are thinking about
some kind of black scenario some kind of
de-escalation of the war in ukraine
trying to use this these escalations
or
threatening threatenings
uh by drawing as they already mentioned
we have everybody to be said all right
so your argument is that russia is
making noise here but if it if it came
to any kind of
military action
against lithuania are you confident that
as a nato member the alliance would come
to lithuania's aid
of course of course because if not so
then
it will be no nato at all
uh of course russia is trying to test
nato to test other alliances
but today you know
they know very well themselves who they
are
kaliningrad region is now
less
deployments are
with military personnel are less than it
was before the war against ukraine
because they need
personnel military personnel in ukraine
so we know this
also we know that there are no
nothing no new movements military
movements around up to now up to this
moment i speak with you it is the noise
it is the
information attack because yesterday
today many
media outlets informed that
lithuania blocked somehow uh this
transit is not true so this is this is
what
russia used to do and is doing all the
time with information for their lives
and and maybe for domestic affairs as
well uh all right lithuania is a part of
the eu these are eu sanctions one has to
wonder though why tiny lithuania would
be doing this at the behest of of the eu
it's it's it's kind of poking a bear
with a stick isn't it asking for trouble
but we are not doing ourselves such as
agreement of uh
27 uh
countries unilateral union
in one voice was adopted sanctions uh
15th of march
fourth package later
fifth package six package so we are part
of european union and of course uh
russia has to be punished uh with
sanctions because of the war they
launched brutal bloody war they are
killing people so it's uh it's uh
they they they can immediately solve
this problem with sanctions and with the
with the transit as well uh
if if they will stop this war so
everybody asks them to stop this war
it's been really good to talk to you
many thanks indeed uh for being with us
much appreciated rasa
russia's president says that he's
planning to fully modernize the military
vladimir putin says it's in response to
growing threats from outside the country
the plans include making russia's ground
troops more combat effective for future
conflict conflicts
we will continue to develop and
strengthen our armed forces taking into
account potential military threats and
risks based on the lessons of modern
armed conflicts a priority is equipping
troops with new weapon systems that will
determine the combat effectiveness of
the army and navy in the years and
decades to come in addition to the new
weapons already tested troops are
receiving s 500 air defense and missile
defense systems that are unmatched in
the world
in ukraine a school in the eastern
donetsk region has been hit by russian
shelling a regional governor released
this footage showing the building in
flames in the city of abdivka
it's
one of about a 200 schools destroyed
across the donetsk region
there's been fierce fighting for several
weeks as russian and ukrainian forces
battle for control of the east well the
situation